Niederlage bei der impfpflichtabstimmung
im Bundestag heute es ist die Klatsche
für Kanzler Scholz und
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach die
Einführung einer corona-impfpflicht ist
gescheitert hatte keine Mehrheit heute
im Bundestag
was hatte er gekämpft geworben ja fast
schon gebettelt Gesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach und seine Impfpflicht wir
haben heute die Möglichkeit
90 der Todesfälle die vermeidbar sind
durch ein Impfpflicht zu vermeiden
nutzen wir bitte diese Gelegenheit am
Donnerstag das Duell im Bundestag
Abstimmung über eben diese Impfpflicht
ab 60 Jahren harter Widerstand jedoch
aus dem Lager der impfpflichtgegner es
ist nämlich nicht die Aufgabe des
Staates erwachsenen Menschen gegen ihren
Willen zum Selbstschutz zu zwingen hinzu
kommt das mittlerweile sogar doppelt
geimpfte in der Statistik als ungeimpft
gelten wenn ihre letzte Impfung ein
halbes Jahr zurückliegt wie gut die
Impfung gegen künftige Mutationen
schützt weiß kein Mensch das Ergebnis
683 abgegebene Stimmen 296 dafür
378 dagegen 9 Enthaltungen eine Klatsche
eine Klatsche vor allem aber auch für
Kanzler Olaf Scholz er war für die
Impfpflicht so wie auch Vizekanzler
Robert Habeck Außenministerin Annalen
Innenministerin Nancy fazer und und und
und und und das Volk wenn ihr impft
dreimal
also bin ich dafür ja ich bin über 60
und ich will sie nicht also ich hätte es
befürwortet wenn die ab 50 dann als
Pflicht gegolten hätte also ich bin
wirklich gebustert ich habe alles aber
ich möchte eigentlich keine vierte
Spritze mehr haben ich glaube wir haben
jetzt andere Probleme als eine
Impfpflicht momentan Lauterbach ist ja
doch irgendwie hat er in der letzten
Zeit merkwürdiges Bild abgegeben in
meinen Augen und wer gedacht hat das
letzte Wort ist gesprochen Karl
Lauterbach hat bereits angekündigt wir
machen weiter das heißt dann wohl auch
Karl Lauterbach als talkshow-minister
weiterhin auf allen Kanälen im
Kampfmodus hoffen wir dass sich Scholz
und Lauterbach bald von ihren klatschen
erholen
aus unserer Politikredaktion der jetzt
hier bei mir guten Abend Julius das ist
schon eine richtige Klatsche hier für
den Kanzler aber vor allem auch für den
Gesundheitsminister beide haben ja immer
wieder betont wie wichtig die
Impfpflicht ist ja das ist eine
klatschen Serie es ging ja die ganze
Woche durch am Wochenende musste oder
hat Beginn der Woche musste wurde der
Kompromiss Vorschlag von dem Team um
Karl Lauterbach bekannt gegeben
Impfpflicht ab 50 soll sondern sein die
ab 80 wurde schon mal gestrichen dann
kam es zu keinem richtigen zu keiner
richtigen Einigung hat man sich
angenähert und gesagt die Impfpflicht ab
60 soll es aber sein da haben sich
zumindest schon mal zwei Gruppen
zusammengetan aber auch da war nicht
klar wird es eine Mehrheit geben dann
hat es Lauterbach noch versucht mit
einem parlamentarischen Trick er wollte
die abstimmungsreihenfolge ändern nicht
mal dafür hatte die Ampel heute Mittag
eine Mehrheit und am Ende wurde dann
zuerst über den Antrag die Impfpflicht
ab 60 abgestimmt und die wurde mit dem
niederschwenderten Ergebnis
zurückgewiesen
296 Jahr Stimmen waren es am Ende nur
über 340 die Nein gestimmt haben das ist
schon sehr sehr deutlich
aber trotzdem wir machen weiter man muss
was fragen Julius was hat man als zu
fürchten ja hat angekündigt dass er
weiter dafür kämpfen würde er als Arzt
müsse das tun und um die Gesundheit der
Menschen zu kämpfen nur sagen viele
andere Mediziner moment mal wir wissen
noch gar nicht ob überhaupt eine Gefahr
droht im Herbst wir haben im Moment die
Augen Variante wir erleben ist alles
gibt unfassbar hohe Fallzahl unfassbar
hohe Dunkelziffer und trotzdem
vergleichsweise wenig schwerer schwer
kranke oder tote Menschen und Lauterbach
geht davon aus dass im Herbst eine
todbringende schlimmere Variante als
Omegon kommt das ist nicht unmöglich
aber auf gar keinen Fall die
wahrscheinlichste Variante und darauf
würde sich vorbereiten oder viele
Mediziner sagen und auch Politiker sagen
ich kann mich nicht mit einer
grundrechtseinschränkung wie einer
Impfpflicht auch etwas vorbereiten von
dem ich noch gar nicht weiß ob es
wirklich kommen wird welche Mittel hätte
er denn da überhaupt geht dann alles
noch einmal von vorne los also history
peating wieder ab in den Bundestag
wieder Vorschläge die dann abgelehnt
werden also welche Möglichkeiten hat er
überhaupt naja gut ein Gesetz
einzubringen kann genau man kann als
sich als Gruppe versammeln ein ein
Antrag oder ein Gesetz einbringen und
abstimmen lassen ob es dann eine bessere
Variante ist ob es dann irgendwie
Kniffe gibt die die Union überzeugen die
andere Fraktion überzeugen ist eine
andere Frage und natürlich ganz
entscheidend wird eines Tages wieder das
Momentum auf der Seite von Cloud aber
sein nämlich dass wir wieder Probleme
bekommen dass wir beispielsweise im
Herbst steigende Fallzahlen haben weil
wieder die Herbstsaison losgeht die
Menschen nach drinnen gehen und sich
gegenseitig anstecken vielleicht auch
die Wirkung des Impfstoffs nach und nach
lässt das jetzt Momentum auf seiner
Seite hat das wäre noch ein Thema aber
letzten Endes muss er wieder den Weg
über das Parlament gehen also eventuell
alles noch einmal von vorne wir sprechen
jetzt mit Kassenärzte Chef dr Andreas
Gassner uns zugeschaltet guten Abend die
Klatsche für den Gesundheitsminister
haben sie sich darüber heute ein
bisschen gefreut oder fürchten sie auch
wie er den Herbst und was da auf uns
zukommen möge
das hat mit vorhin gar nichts zu tun
also es ist ja völlig unstrittig dass
nach wie vor die Impfung gegen Corona
insbesondere für ältere und für
Risikogruppen das sinnvollste ist und
das kann man aus medizinischer Sicht nur
empfehlen dass das mit der Impfpflicht
jetzt nicht Gesetz gerade erlangt hat
das ist die entscheidende durch den
Bundestag vertreten Souveräns durch den
die Bürger und das muss man glaube ich
mal akzeptieren das ist dann wenig
zielführend fünf Minuten danach zu sagen
wir machen weiter ich glaube dass die
Impfpflicht gescheitert es ist auch ein
Gutteil da durch Herrn Lauterbach selbst
verursacht worden weil ja das narrativ
was er über die letzten Monate gepflegt
hat sich ständig gewandelt hat er beim
Oktober ja noch gegen eine Impfpflicht
gut begründet ehrlich gesagt und hat
jetzt zuletzt Begründung für eine
mögliche angeführt die offenkundig
einfach nicht tragen so hilft halt die
Impfung die wir im Moment haben nicht
gegen eine Infektion es gibt also
keinerlei fremdschutz sie hilft
individuell und da muss man natürlich
klar sagen junge gesunde Menschen sind
natürlich eben sehr geringen Umfängen
nur von der Gefahr einer wirklich
schweren Verlaufsform bedroht das ist
mehr was von für Angehörige von
Risikogruppen und ältere Menschen und
das sollte man viel besser eine eine
Impfkampagne fahren damit die im Herbst
geschützt sind das wäre glaube ich
zielführender gewesen als diese völlig
irratischen Diskussion mit
verschiedensten Anträgen die alle für
sich nicht wirklich überzeugen konnten
sehen sie überhaupt noch Erfolgschancen
für eine Impfpflicht
das kann ich nicht beurteilen das ist
eine entscheidende der Bundestag treffen
muss ich habe nicht die Fantasie warum
der Deutsche Bundestag in vier Wochen
anders entscheiden sollte also heute
entschieden hat es sei denn morgen ist
die von einer Lauterbach immer
beschworene horrorvariante am Horizont
zu erkennen das ist bisher völlig unklar
und wir müssten Impfstoff haben der
gegen eine solche neue Variante wirkt
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
es hier jetzt das parlamentarische in
den nächsten zwei Wochen wieder anlaufen
ist auch nicht unser Thema das ist eine
politische Entscheidung eines Tages ich
als Arzt und ich vertrete ja nun die
Ärztin und Ärzte in Deutschland und die
haben ein großes Bestreben möglichst
viele Menschen durch eine Impfung zu
schützen das ist auch unstrittig dazu
stehen wir zur Verfügung und wir
bewerben die Impfung insbesondere für
kranke
ältere Menschen und andere Risikogruppen
und ich denke das sollte vielmehr über
diesen Aspekt laufen die Impfpflicht hat
doch aus meiner Sicht im Moment erstmal
ausgedient
sagte kassenärztechef Dr Andreas Gassen
vielen herzlichen Dank Ihnen für das
Gespräch
und wir sprechen weiter und ich begrüße
jetzt Christian dürr Fraktion
Vorsitzender der
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion schönen guten
Abend Ihnen Herr Dörr
das heute geht kann man als Klatsche für
die Ampel verstehen tun sie das auch
ich befürchte Herr Dörr wir haben gerade
Tonprobleme wir können Sie leider nicht
hören wir arbeiten da noch einmal dran
ich sehe sie sind uns zugeschaltet aber
gerade müssen wir da noch einmal am Ton
arbeiten damit wir sie auch hören können
daran arbeiten wir jetzt Julius Böhm
mein Kollege aus der Politik noch weiter
bei uns im Studio jetzt haben wir es
gehört die Erfolgschancen werden nicht
gerade hoch ausgerechnet und auch von
ärztlicher Seite heißt es lieber eine
Kampagne als die Impfpflicht man hat das
Gefühl dieses Thema ist irgendwie vom
Tisch und gleichzeitig steigt aber die
Verunsicherung auch wenn wir auf die
vergangene Woche blicken denn hieß es
erst die Quarantäne nur noch freiwillig
das würde dann kassiert mitten in der
Nacht das löst irgendwie glaube ich bei
der Bevölkerung auch viel Verunsicherung
aus wie steht die Politik da gerade da
mit der kommunikativ definitiv nicht
sehr gut man kann von einem
kommunikationsdesaster sprechen was
diese Woche passiert ist
Minister Lauterbach wollte die
quarantänepflicht zum ersten Mai
abschaffen eine ganz logischer Schritt
weil bei den hohen Fallzahlen der Moment
über 4 Millionen Menschen die
gleichzeitig Corona positiv sind kommt
kein Gesundheitsamt dieser Welt
hinterher
das wäre also einfach nur logisch eine
eine Regel die so auf dem Papier
existiert aber auch in der Realität
nicht umgesetzt wird einfach
abzuschaffen
Ämter weniger zu tun und die Menschen LK
sich nicht wurde aber zurückgerufen
nachdem Lauterbach viel Kritik bekommen
hat in der eigenen Fraktion von Experten
aber auch vor allem von einer harten
Kern an corona-maßnahmen Befürwortern
die bei Social Media kritisiert haben so
ein hin und her sorgt einfach nur für
Verwirrung und das wichtigste für
Maßnahmen ist eigentlich die Akzeptanz
jetzt gerade habe ich gehört ich glaube
Christian Dörr klappt dich ich höre noch
einmal nachher bei uns jetzt
zugeschaltet ist wir hatten gerade eben
eine technische Probleme entschuldigen
sie bitte wir wollen den
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion sprechen und da
ist auch wieder Christian du jetzt bei
uns in ich hoffe auch sehr wir können
sie hören denn uns interessiert
natürlich sehr ob sie das heutige
Ergebnis für als Klatsche für die Ampel
verstehen
ja ich kann sie wunderbar von vielen
Dank guten Abend erstmal nein das ist
natürlich keine Klatsche für irgendeine
Regierungskoalition sondern es war von
Anfang an eine medizinetische Debatte
das heißt es war keine Frage von
politischer und parteipolitischer
Farbenlehre sondern jede Abgeordnete hat
für sich entschieden insofern kann man
nicht von Mehrheiten aus Opposition oder
Regierung Deutsch sprechen der Deutsche
Bundestag hat aus der Mitte heraus
entschieden jeder einzelne Abgeordnete
für sich ich übrigens auch im Dezember
muss ich sagen hätte ich eine
Impfpflicht noch näher gestanden
österreich hat sie ja damals eingeführt
hat sie jetzt wieder ausgesetzt aus
gutem Grund ich bin für diese
Entscheidung Dezember getroffen haben
und die Zeit genommen haben genau zu
analysieren ob es sinnvoll ist und der
Gassen hatte das ja vorhin in ihrem
Gespräch sehr deutlich gesagt wir haben
zurzeit keinen Impfstoff für eine
Variante im Herbst das heißt es würde
ein Impfpflicht jetzt insofern keinen
Sinn machen und zu einer politischen
Entscheidung gehört dazu dass man sich
die dass man sich genau informiert und
dann entscheiden trifft und Meinung war
ein nein für mich im übrigen ich habe
mich auch gegen eine Pflicht entschieden
sehen Sie dann überhaupt noch
Erfolgschancen für die Impfpflicht wir
machen weiter sagt der
Gesundheitsminister also das ganze noch
einmal von vorne
also ich es geht nicht darum das ganze
noch mal von vorne zu machen das hätte
ich auch in der Sache für falsch ich
glaube es geht jetzt darum jetzt ist es
etwas laut hier im Deutschen Bundestag
weil gerade eine an
vielen herzlichen Dank Herr dir leider
haben wir Tonprobleme nicht nur der
Bundestag der Durchsage macht sondern
auch die Technik spielen hier ein
bisschen verrückt wir danken Ihnen
trotzdem für dieses kurze Gespräch danke
dass Sie sich die Zeit genommen haben
und entschuldigen Sie liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer dass es
dort Tonprobleme